the Greek philosopher Aristotle said if
something doesn't exist there's no word
for it and if there's no word for
something that something doesn't exist
so when we talk about elections we in
established democracies we know what
we're talking about we've got the words
we have the vocabulary we know what a
polling station is we know what a ballot
paper is but what about countries where
democracy doesn't exist countries where
there are no words to describe the
concepts that underpin a Democratic
Society I work in the field of electoral
assistance so that's to say we assist
emerging democracies to organize what is
often their first elections when people
ask me what I do quite often I get this
answer
oh so you're one of these people who
goes around the world
imposing Western democracy on countries
that can't handle it well the United
Nations does not impose anything on
anybody
it really doesn't and also what we do is
firmly anchored in the 1948 Universal
Declaration of Human Rights article 21
that says that everybody should have the
right to choose who governs them so
that's the basis of the work I
specialized in public outreach what does
that mean another jargon it actually
means designing information campaigns so
that candidates and voters who've never
had the opportunity to participate or to
vote understand where when how to
register where when how to vote why why
is it important to take part so I'll
probably devise specific campaign to
reach out to women to make sure that
they can take part that they can be part
of the process young people as well
all sorts of people handicapped people
we try to reach everybody and it's not
always easy because very often in this
work I've noticed now over the years
that I've been doing it that words are
lacking and so what do you do
Afghanistan it's a country with high
levels of illiteracy and the thing about
that was it was in 2005 and we organized
two elections on the same day the reason
was because the logistics are so
incredibly difficult it seemed to be
more efficient to do that it was but on
the other hand explaining to elections
since is that one was even more
complicated so we used a lot of images
and when it came to the actual ballot we
had problems because so many people
wanted to take part we had 300
candidates for 52 sees in the Wallasey
Jirga which is the parliamentary
elections and for the provincial council
we had even more candidates we had 334
54 seats so talking about ballot design
this is what the pilot looked like it's
a size of a newspaper
this was the Wallaces Jirga ballot yeah
and this was the provincial council
ballot even more so you see we did use a
lot of symbols and things like that and
we had other problems in southern Sudan
Southern Sudan was a very different
story we had so many people who'd never
of course voted but we heard extremely
extremely high levels of illiteracy very
very poor infrastructure for example I
mean it's a country the size of Texas
more or less we had 7 kilometers of
paved road 7 kilometers in the whole
country and that includes the tarmac
where we landed the plains and Juba
Apple so transporting electrometer on
etc is exceedingly difficult people had
no idea
about what a box look like it was very
complicated and so using verbal
communication was obviously the way to
go but there were 132 languages so that
was extremely challenging then I arrived
in Tunisia in 2011 it was the Arab
Spring huge amount of of hope was
generated by that enormous movement that
was going on in the region there was
Libya there was a there was Yemen it
was an enormous enormous historical
moment and I was sitting with the
Election Commission and we were talking
about various aspects of the of the of
the election and I was hearing them
using words that I hadn't actually heard
before and I'd worked with Iraqis I'd
worked with the Jordanian Egyptians and
suddenly they were using these words and
I just thought this is strange and what
really gave rise to it was this word
observer we were discussing election
observers and the Election Commissioner
was talking about a mullah 'has in
Arabic but so this means to notice a
sort of in a passive sort of sense that
as in I noticed he was wearing a light
blue shirt did I go and check whether
the shirt was light blue or not that is
the role of an election observer it's
it's very active it's governed by all
kinds of treaties and it has got that
control function in it and then I got
wind of the fact that in Egypt they were
using this term litter bit which means
to follow so we then really haven't
followers of an election so so that's
not quite right either because there is
a term that's already accepted that in
use which was the word more active which
means a controller has got that notion
of control so he'll three words for one
concept all this is not good and with
our colleagues we thought well perhaps
it's our role to actually help make sure
that the words are understood and
actually creates a work of reference
that could be used across the Arab
region and that's what we did so
together with these colleagues we
launched the Arabic lexicon of election
terminology and we worked in eight
different countries it meant actually
defining 481 terms which form the basis
of
everything you need to know if you're
going to organize a democratic election
and we define these terms and we we work
with the our colleagues and came to an
agreement about what would be the
appropriate yet word to use in Arabic
because the Arabic language is is very
rich and that's part of the problem but
there are 22 countries that speak Arabic
and they use modern Standard Arabic
which is the Arabic that's used across
the whole region in newspapers and
broadcasts but of course then from one
country to the next in day-to-day
language and use it varies dialect
colloquialisms etc so that was another
added layer of complication so in one
sense you heard the problem that
language wasn't fully ripe if you like
it was neologism so were coming up new
expressions and so we defined all these
terms and then we had a correspondence
and in the in the region we submitted
the draft to them they responded back to
us yes we understand the definition we
agree with it but this is what we say in
our country because we were not going to
harmonize or force harmonization we were
trying to facilitate understanding among
people so in yellow you see the
different expressions in use in the
various countries so this I'm happy to
say it took three years to produce this
because we also finalized the draft and
took it actually into the field sat with
the Election Commission so all these
different countries debated and defined
and refined the draft and finally
published it in November of 2014 in
Cairo and it's gone a long way we
published 10000 copies to date there's
about 3,000 downloads of the of the
Internet in PDF form I heard just
recently from a colleague that they've
taken it up in Somalia they're going to
produce a version of this in Somalia
because there's nothing in Somalia at
all so that's that's very you know good
to know and this newly formed Arab
Association of election management
bodies which is trying to
professionalize how elections are run in
the region they're using it as well
and the Arab League have now built up a
pan-arab observation unit and they're
using it so that's all really good
however this work of references is quite
high-pitched its complex and a lot of
the terms are quite technical so the
average person probably doesn't need to
know at least a third of it but the
people of the Middle East have been
deprived of any form of what we know as
civic education it's part of our
curriculum at school it doesn't really
exist in that part of the world and I
feel it's really the right of everybody
to know how these things work and it's a
good thing to think about producing a
work of reference for the average person
and bearing in mind that now we have a
basis to work with but also we also have
technology so we can reach out with
using telephone apps
video animation there's all sorts of
tools that can be used now to
communicate these ideas to people for
the first time in their own language we
hear a lot of misery about the Middle
East we hear the chaos of war we hear
terrorism we hear about sectarianism and
all this horrible negative news that
comes to us all the time what we're not
hearing is what are the people the
everyday people thinking what are
they're aspiring to let's give them the
means let's give them the words the
silent majority is silent because they
don't have the words the silent majority
needs to know it is time to provide
people with the knowledge tools that
they can inform themselves with the
silent majority does not need to be
silent let's help them have a voice
thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]